[Music]
in less than 30 years amazon went from
selling books to selling everything you
can imagine
opening up grocery stores offering a
selection of movies and tv shows
and one day plans to launch a satellite
internet service
the company's growth has been nothing
short of stunning
in 1995 the year the site went live it
made half a million dollars in sales
in 2020 that soared to 386
billion so how did amazon get so big
by following one simple rule over and
over again
customer obsession is the key to the
success of amazon or
amazon.com as it was known at the start
that focus on the customer led jeff
bezos to start off by selling books
he believed that would appeal to people
the most as he explained during the
company's early days
there are more items in the book
category than there are items in any
other category by far
a web store would not be limited by the
physical constraints of a bookstore
so customers could quickly and easily
get their hands on whatever they wanted
like this title about computer modeling
the first book the company ever sold
in those early days bezos and a small
team packaged and mailed off the orders
themselves
other online bookstores existed at the
time so amazon had to find a way to set
itself apart
by adding user-generated reviews again
the company thought about what would be
best for the customer though not
necessarily the publishing house
bezos once recalled receiving an unhappy
letter from a publisher about the
feature
one wrote to me and said you don't
understand your business you make money
when you sell things
why do you allow these negative customer
reviews
and when i read that letter i thought we
don't make money when we sell things
we make money when we help customers
make purchase decisions
in other words amazon stuck to its core
principle build the best customer
experience
possible which extended to more features
in 1999
the company patented the one click
button which lets you skip the shopping
cart purchasing any item quickly and
easily as the website remembers your
previously entered payment and address
information
the patent lasted all the way until 2017
when barnes noble implemented a similar
feature amazon sued
forcing the bookseller to add an extra
step at checkout
some argue that patents during the tech
boom of the 90s were too broad
and too powerful one click was a huge
asset for the company
it needed any advantage it could get
when the dot-com bubble burst
causing amazon to lose over 90 percent
of its valuation
it went from a split adjusted initial
public offering of a dollar fifty a
share in 1997
to a 106.69 cents a share in december
1999
before falling all the way back down to
5.97 a share
in september 2001. unlike many other
tech firms
amazon managed to survive by raising a
ton of money just before the market
crashed
during these turbulent years bezos made
moves that would define his company
chief among them lowering prices in the
early 2000s amazon decided to cut the
price of some items by 30 or
40 percent in some cases its thinking
went something like this
low prices attract more customers which
increases sales
which attracts more third-party sellers
who pay a commission and store their
goods at amazon's warehouses for faster
delivery
since more items are now going through
these fulfillment centers which have
fixed fees like the lease
this lowers the per unit cost which
saves the company more money
enabling it to lower prices even further
and the cycle repeats
there was just one hurdle to overcome
amazon had started to diversify beyond
books but was having trouble convincing
customers to purchase items
in multiple categories so i needed to
offer an
incentive amazon realized that one of
the biggest barriers to shopping online
was the expensive shipping so it
introduced free super saver shipping in
2002
for those who spent over 99 then it kept
lowering the minimum purchase threshold
first to forty nine dollars then twenty
five dollars
customers started to fill their virtual
baskets with more products from
different categories
setting the stage in 2005 for amazon
prime
forever changing the way we shop prime
members could
receive unlimited two-day shipping on
all orders for a flat annual fee
of 79 the math didn't make much sense
amazon would in fact lose money but
bezos bet the membership would prompt
customers to buy more
and that's exactly what happened
customers signed up like crazy
further expanding amazon's market share
as bradstone details in his book about
the company
an amazon executive likened signing up
for prime as going from a dial up to a
broadband internet connection two-day
shipping eventually led to one day
in same-day shipping and now amazon is
developing a drone service that aims to
deliver packages in just
30 minutes ironically after creating a
global retail giant online
the company is now opening brick and
mortar stores with a twist
you never have to wait in line at amazon
go convenience stores
shoppers walk in swipe their phone like
a boarding pass at the airport
while ai-powered sensors track their
purchase and automatically charge their
credit card via the amazon app there's
no need to go to a cashier or a
self-check kiosk
however such rapid and continual growth
doesn't come without criticism
there have been allegations in the past
that workers in the warehouses were so
exhausted
they had panic attacks or fell asleep on
their feet
the firm is also accused of acting like
a monopoly when launching the kindle in
2007
amazon decided to price electronic books
at just 9.99
hoping to tilt the book business toward
e-reading by offering customers a steal
publishers suspected the low price would
hurt them as amazon could use its market
power to then demand
cheaper wholesale prices in a famous
dispute over pricing
amazon temporarily took away the buy
button on titles from the publisher
macmillan
only offering them through outside
vendors despite accusations of brutal
bullying tactics
the goal of amazon has always been to
pass on more savings to customers
and customers are responding amazon
delivered a record performance in 2020
with net sales increasing
38 compared to the year before as the
pandemic led people to buy more online
the secret sauce of amazon where there
are several principles at amazon
but the number one thing that has made
us successful by far
is obsessive compulsive focus on the
customer
as opposed to obsession over the
competitor
there's a great interview on
curiositystream that gives an inside
look into jeff bezos's mindset
and what made his company a stunning
success you can watch
thousands of documentaries on
curiositystream i have a whole list to
get through on a variety of topics
including space
science tech and history and if you head
to curiositystream.com
newsthink it's just 15 for the entire
year
not month but year the link is in my
description
and be sure to use my promo code
newsthink thanks so much for watching
for news think i'm cindy palm